Hey. Hello and welcome to today's episode of
Rawkode live. I am your host Rawkode.
Today we're diving back into our Laravel on
Kubernetes journey and I am joined by a
previous guest friend and
budding conference joiner beer drinker
Alex Bowers. Hey mate, how are you? I'm
good. Thanks. You? I'm I'm alright. Actually, I'm
doing quite well. I'm excited to come back
to my my Laravel stuff here and and
see what we're doing. Like
we've done well, sorry. I I think I've
done five or six episodes on this now.
You joined us for one of those and
you reached out and said, there's still a
few things that we haven't covered yet. Do
you wanna give us well, first, just a
little introduction about yourself and then we'll talk
about what we wanna try and cover today.
Yeah. Sure. So I'm Alex. I am a
lead developer at a ecommerce platform in The
UK called ShopBlocks.
We use Laravel
a lot, and we're
working towards moving into Kubernetes and Docker alongside
some of our previous infrastructure stuff using.
And that's basically why I reached out because
some of the previous streams have
some topics which
more collaboration or
haven't been covered yet. So, hopefully, we can
cover those today and and if not today
soon.
I've got a full list of full
list of stuff to cover on the post
and note here, so we'll see where we
get to in it, but there's quite a
few things in there.
We'll certainly try and cross a few of
them off, and I'm always more than happy
to schedule more of these if we want
in the future. And I really wanna make
sure that we cover
everything that teams like yours need to get
their Laravel application running on Kubernetes
successfully.
So we'll do our best.
Alright.
Why don't we talk a little bit about
what you're prepared? So we're not using like
a real production grade application today. Right? You
you've put something together that is gonna be
is it close to that? Is it gonna
use the components that are missing last time?
Give us a little flavor on that.
Yeah. So what I've created is
not something anybody would ever use in production.
It's got two endpoints.
One of them creates some jobs,
and one of them is a
sends an email. The email that says, hello,
world. Like, it's very minimalist, but it adds
things to the queue. It has some scheduled
tasks to run-in the background.
It does some
it has some assets which can be compiled
and
just things like that, which every team will
have. None of them will be as basic
as this, but if you get the infrastructure
down to run a scheduled task, it doesn't
matter what the task is. If you've got
stuff in the background to run queues, it
doesn't matter what the queue job is. So
we've just got some simple code to run
that stuff.
Alright. Sweet. Let me just pull up the
the repository.
So it's on gethub.com
username Alex bevers slash Laravel dash example
dash project.
I
already have this cloned
here.
We have a live share configured so I
I should see yep. There's your name there.
So we're now in a position where we
can try to address some of those concerns
and that we're missing. Do you wanna just
quickly run through that list you've and then
we're trying to say what is best to
kick things off with?
Yeah. So
one of the things that's probably best to
start with, I guess, is migrations. Literally every
application I can ever think of requires migrations
to run. And you've touched this briefly in
the past showing
well, not showing, but saying how it would
be done. And I think the example still
had, like, a b c as, like, the
art into
into the
the the worker.
So that's that's probably the main one. There's
the two big things beyond that, I guess,
is queue jobs and schedule jobs. So on
a normal server, you'd run supervisor,
and you'd have
several different workers scheduled to run-in the background
to run a specific command called q
work.
Obviously,
it isn't gonna be exactly the same as
that in Kubernetes, so the but it'll be
similar, I assume.
And then there's also scheduled task, which normally
you'd use a contract for
on your server.
That's I believe
it's like a scheduled tasks built into Kubernetes.
So I assume that's how we manage that
as well. But those are the three main
things I'd say, which
most applications will make use of at some
point.
Beyond that, there's a couple of things like
managing your secrets.
So you got EUV stuff,
how that could be released in config map.
That's less likely to be an issue because
you can just inject it in the Docker
file
sorry, in your Docker
image.
Then there's also things like asset deployment, which
you covered in the past. So that's less
of an issue then. Yeah.
Alright. Yeah. There there there's a fair amount
in there. Let's let's just see what we
can get through it and then if we
need to schedule more time, we will definitely
do that and take it all.
I think because you've gone to the effort
to produce this application,
what we'll try and do is I'll just
try and send as many pull requests as
I can to it during this episode as
we kinda work through this together
and anything else. We'll just try and make
this the default example for Kubernetes on file
or Laravel on Kubernetes actually.
Alright. So
let's see database migrations first then. Let's see
what you've got in place for actually running
this on Kubernetes and in fact, I I
I don't have any Kubernetes right now. Hold
on. Let me start Docker.
Okay. So we do have a Docker compose
file.
That is a default one that comes with
Laravel. I've not touched that whatsoever. That's a
development environment only, I think. Something new that
came with Laravel
a few months ago from Laravel sale. Fun
fact. I sent a pull request to the
Laravel project
three or four years ago with a Docker
file and they said, sorry. We don't wanna
support Docker. Just there you go. Just throwing
that out there. I'm not better. Just saying.
They now they now have, like, a first
party product
called
Vapor, which is to deploy onto AWS Lambda.
And so I assume that's pushed much more
on the getting
Docker working because they now make money from
it. So
Alright. Well, I'm just clicking the magic reset
Kubernetes
because I can't remember the last thing I
was doing, but that's to be fair. So
that's now reset and we'll wait for that
to become healthy.
Let's see. So that Docker
compose file, that is not anything I've touched
at all. I've not done anything for
development. All I've done is create two Docker
files, which are inside resources ops Docker.
I've got two in there. I've got an
n engine x one and one f p
m one.
Those are the files which I've
started.
Okay. Well, I mean, this
this won't work by default unless we use
sale.
I I don't actually see a Docker file
here. Am I being silly?
So inside it's inside of the
vendor.
So when you do a page install, you
will get a
a vendor file vendor folder which has Laravel
sale in there, and that has different times.
You can specify which one, and it will
compile based that.
Alright. That's the half composer.
I don't
alright.
I
don't believe that you would require Laravel sale
for this. That would just be for development
environment only.
With with Yeah. Let's Yeah. You're right. I'm
I'm I'm gonna get sidetracked there. I was
gonna start putting together a development environment for
this. And to be honest I think that's
what you've been covered mostly. Sorry. I'd I'd
yeah. I I don't think it's important. I'm
just gonna create a Docker file. We just
want an image with this application in it.
That's that's all I need. And I'm gonna
use Have you
done it? It creates a Docker file,
which will build an PM and the engine
x image separately.
Where are those? Resources ops.
Ah, is this based on prior art from
other episodes? Is well, that's exactly a copy
of the previous streams. Alright. Okay. Good. So
we don't need I separated them out into
two separate rather than having the make file
specify individual targets. I've made it so that
they
are just two separate two separate jobs because
the overlap was very minimal.
Oh, that's I think that's a good or
bad idea but that's yeah. It's embedded. Alright.
And you've already added make target. This is
already my favorite episode ever because you've done
all the work. Okay.
Let's build these then. So I'll just make
sure I got the target names. We'll do
build. Let's build FPM first and then we'll
do build NGINX.
Okay. So that's gonna give us our two
images which
you know, for anyone that's watching,
go watch the previous episodes, we'll add the
links into the description afterwards.
It walks you through the entire process. We're
gonna assume
that we're starting from the point we've already
built your FPM NGINX images and pushed them
to some container registry and we're gonna try
and get this working on Kubernetes with all
the bells and whistles that we've omitted previously.
Are you going to be doing this on
Kubernetes locally? I assume are you going to
be doing this on
production
cloud environment?
I'm just gonna use Docker for Mac unless
you feel there's a reason we would need
to have an alternative cluster.
But I don't think The only thing that
I would say, purely because I don't know
much about it locally is external load balances
and how those sort things work, but that
can be covered in a far later episode
anyway.
Yeah. I have I have done previous episodes
on ingress and load balancing on Kubernetes
that aren't they're not Laravel specific and I
don't think they have to be.
No. So that's a problem. IP and all
that sort of thing should be fine. Yeah.
That's that's that'll be alright. I mean, we
can talk a little bit about how the
the services and the ingress work together, but
I don't think I I don't need a
cloud environment just to kinda show that off.
Yeah. That that's fine.
I don't think there's anything else that I
could think of that is massively different
from development or local environment to production environment.
So Alright.
Well, it looks like we do have a
little bit of time to kill while this
builds. Maybe I should have kicked that off
previously.
However, if anyone watching has any questions that
they want us to address, feel free to
drop that in the comments or drop me
a
tweet
at Rawkode.
So
let me try and understand the migration path
here. So we're gonna be using the artisan
command,
which I don't think is ever important in
here. We went through this previously. Yeah.
Which has to run a DB migrate.
Is that correct? It's PHP artisan migrate.
So does that I I need a database
deployed to my Kubernetes cluster then. Right? Yes.
I've not touched anything to do that yet.
Alright. Sweet. Finally, something I can do. Okay.
That yeah. I've tested this locally with MySQL.
It shouldn't make any difference because it's all
using the RM. But yeah. Alright. What database
do you want?
Let's get MySQL eight.
Well, MariaDB 10 or whatever is here.
Alright.
So I'm assuming you don't really need me
to go through the production deployment mechanisms for
MariaDB. We're happy just to use something that's
MariaDB on Kubernetes. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. So personally for me, I avoid
running any databases myself anyway. Just probably use
managed services. Save so much effort and
well, some people I guess will be running
in this. Well, if anyone that is going,
hey, I wanna know how to do it
under production. Just use helm. Go and use
the
go and use work from other people. There's
a helm chart says the artifact hub. Let's
talk about that actually. So
artifact hub.
This is from the CNCF.
It hosts all of the CNCF projects artifacts.
Go figure. Helm is one of those where
we can just say, hey, give me MariaDB.
We could filter on helm charts if we
wanted.
We click this and everything you need to
know to get a pretty production grade deployment
or MariaDB is gonna be here. You can
use helm, you tweak the values based on
whatever you need and you deploy it.
Probably what I would recommend.
However, for today, I'm not gonna do that
just because I just want something quick. What
I am gonna do is check the
environment bars I need. I know I need
to set the MySQL root password, maybe a
user database. I just wanna make sure I
got the version right. So it looks like
we're on 10 is okay. And if I
just search for
my SQL
root password,
these are the variables that I have available
to configure this image.
And I'm gonna drop these in. So we're
just gonna say environment.
We'll get some space.
Let's do
my SQL.
I'm pretty sure there's a random route.
Let's not get too fancy today.
Okay. Let's set a user
and we'll set a value of Laravel.
We'll set the password
Laravel.
Host
no. We don't need the host
database database.
We'll just call it all Laravel. Was that
standard? Is that what you would do in
your application? Would you tweak it more than
that?
So
I would personally name the database something relevant,
but obviously, is
Yeah. I think this is relevant. Perfect. So
Laravel is
yeah. Fine.
Alright. Okay. Cool. And happily, that is also
the default that we have in the dot
m b file. So Oh, is it?
Yeah. The username and password are both different,
but that's easy to change.
Alright. Okay.
Let's deploy
this. Oh, no. We need to expose this.
Okay. So
one of the things we want to do
is when we apply this deployment to Kubernetes,
it's gonna create the pods that run MariaDB
for us. We're gonna by default, the replicas
will be one but we'll make that a
bit more explicit. So we're gonna run one
of these.
However, what we want to do is
make sure we can have service discovery around
this pod which could be pods so that
we can use DNS to actually speak to
it. So I'm I'm gonna add a service
MariaDB.
The selector has to match
what we have above
So you can see app MiriDB matches the
same labels we apply to the deployment.
We don't need the target port because this
is a pretty simple setup. We're just gonna
say
port three three zero six.
So that should be Oh yeah. Good. Those
are built as well, which is handy.
So let's deploy.
Was it resources
ops
Kubernetes,
MaryDB.
Let's check my cluster.
There we go. Too many clusters.
And we should be able to run,
Get pods.
Oh, we have an error. I broke it
because I never set a random root password
and I never set root password.
Yeah. That's the one I want.
It just means that I I won't actually
know the root password which I think is
good. So
value.
And what do do then? You go into
the secrets to extract it or Well, we
already have this user with this database configured.
So we're making sure that we're That's the
root password. Right. Yeah. Yeah. It's just the
root password. So Yeah.
We can just apply that over the top.
We're gonna get pods watch. We can already
see that we have one MariaDB running. The
error one is now terminating
and
that is good. Alright. Database.
Do we require
anything else?
What's the queue processing?
First of all, sorry. What are we using
for the queue?
So the queue can just by default use
MySQL.
You can use Redis. You can use,
like, webMQ and all that sort of stuff.
But by default, you can just make it
run using the database. So I'm just going
to assume that that's the sensible way to
do it.
Okay.
And this deployment that we have here let's
see.
Replicas one. Actually, got all of them. Sorry.
Can you say again, Alex? I'm not sure
why it's got all those things on the
line. They didn't have that online.
That is complaining because I am not setting
the resources
required.
So it's telling me that I could straight
pods I think.
Let's
see.
Resource limits. Yeah. Okay. So
there we go. So we can minimize that
to a single line. Yeah. My my editor
is just like put you know, in production
you don't want to deploy things without resource
limits. You don't want them to just start
consuming all the CPU and memory across your
cluster. So you would see constraint as to
something that I consider to be safe.
Is that per container or is that a
part or is that per node or Yeah.
Per container. So I mean, if we look
at this as an example, right, you know,
we've got engine x here which
really requires nothing.
So we can see that the limits on
this
CPU.
Now complete is only gonna get me so
far.
Let's say 500
mem.
NGINX probably isn't gonna require
too much.
As I connect with it once.
No memory limit. I did set memory limit.
Is it memory? Is it memory?
You're correct. Cool.
Thanks, man.
So we can set that there and then
FPM is probably gonna require more. So I
think what we'll do just for the
for fun, let's just actually set these really
low and we'll see them crash. We'll try
and boost them if we need to. Let's
see what happens.
Yep. Okay. Let's apply
this. So we're just gonna apply our deployment.
I don't what have I got wrong?
Hard to pick it. The error here, it
seems to be complaining.
Okay. My limits can't be unmarshaled.
Quantities must match the regular expression.
Okay. So it doesn't want m I b.
I think it just wants m.
You've got m I b on two places.
Of course, I do. Thanks.
Okay.
Now we can run get pods.
Kind of expect that to fail. Now we
got an image pill policy problem.
You've this set to always. This is a
local cluster.
So we actually want this to be never
because the image doesn't exist on a remote
repository or remote registry.
Okay. So we can just apply that over
the top.
And so what the way image pool policy
works
is that you know,
actually seems quite healthy with those figures. So
we'll leave it for now. But I do
expect that to crash before the end of
the episode. Well we try running anything. Yeah.
Yeah.
You had image pools policy to always and
there are times and places where you want
to use always definitely.
However when you have an image like this
that
let's talk about how this is resolved by
Kubernetes first.
When you do not provide a host for
the registry,
this assumes that your image
is
this.
It assumes that you're an official image on
the docker registry. This is a hangover from
when docker was pretty much the the facto
container runtime
and that it assumed you were always gonna
pull from the docker hub
and that doesn't exist. So when you have
an image pool policy is always in your
cluster, the controllers are gonna reach out and
try to get the latest hash for
that image, it doesn't exist, it fails and
it exits.
So for local images, what you actually need
to do is image pool policy never and
just make sure it's available on the host.
And it's running and it's happy.
However,
our application probably isn't gonna work. First we
haven't done those database migrations that we actually
wanna be doing And secondly, it doesn't know
where MariaDB is yet.
Well, if you try and access it, you
should I assume get error pages using
in the level of a page. Yeah. I
wish I would assume so for sure.
So let's port forward as this port 80?
No.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. It is. Okay.
So we'll make that available on port eighty
eighty locally.
I'm gonna browse to there.
Alright. Well, our first problem is that we
need somewhere to store our logs and we're
getting a permission denied on that.
Let's take a look at what's going on.
So I'm gonna jump inside of this pod.
I hope we got access to bash.
Oh, it's an Alpine one, not mine. Okay.
So we have access to bash.
I didn't look in the Dockerfile
where Well, I
think. Let me just check.
Yeah. That's
our application.
No. That's missing most of it.
That's this is engine actual. Right?
Oh, you mean engine actual? Oh, sorry. I
put in the Yeah.
How is this deployed?
Oh, the names are quite verbose.
Yeah.
I didn't know we're gonna not call in
something just like FPM as a good idea,
so I wouldn't should focus on it. Okay.
Here is our application.
We are actually the root user, so that
directory
failure here,
storage logs. I'm assuming storage doesn't exist.
No.
Storage exists by default.
What the engine access running as WW data
there into?
Oh, sorry. The m PHPFPM.
Let's see.
Of course. Right.
So obviously it's a good idea to not
run containers as well.
Well, there is a little bit of juggling
that has to be done with file system
permissions.
So let's
see the best way to handle this
as to provide
temporary or ephemeral storage for things like that
where we can control the volume that we
wanna make available.
So let's do
okay. So
we can add a volume to our spec.
Let's call this logs.
I think it's a name logs
We want a
empty there.
I don't think that needs any configuration,
size limit, medium, yep. We can just
I can't remember. When in doubt, look it
up. Kubernetes empty there.
Think seems to remember that empty there if
there's anything that does wipe it out as
well. Is that correct? So is that Well,
yeah. We're just using it for cache. Okay.
It's not Yeah. Until the empty object. So
for logs and cache, yeah. I'm totally okay
with that plus to be honest, we're actually
gonna remove
your logging to not be to a fail
and we're gonna move that to standard out.
So that's maybe something we could do first.
However, let's let's try and do it this
way so we can show it working
And then we'll change it up a little
bit. So we now have this volume available.
So empty charges means get create an empty
volume ephemeral when a container or pod dies,
get rid of it. That's it.
Now we wanna provide logging for our FPM.
So we're gonna come in here and we're
gonna see if we have oh, not volume
devices, it's volume mounts.
We're gonna have logs
We wanna mode path of our w html
storage
logs
and we don't need any other flags. Now
this name here just has to match what
we have here, which does
meant it to this location.
There is
a way to configure the empty their
permissions via the security context.
Let's see if we can pull that out
our fingers.
So we can set
let's see if I can find this.
Alright. Well, let's try that in a second.
Let's see what we have first because tomorrow's
I can't remember. We can set effect.
Maybe it depends on the version of Kubernetes
I've got. And this is probably
revealing too much now that that doesn't entirely
useful to the people watching but the security
context
has changed a lot with the recent version
of Kubernetes which is one twenty which I
actually think I'm running
Version.
Yeah.
Client and one nineteen there. Okay. So we
might be okay.
We'll apply first and then I'll walk through
the all those things that are going through
my head.
So let's get pods
and Alex keep me honest here if there's
anything I say that is gibberish just ask
me to elaborate on it because sometimes I
can be bad for that.
That makes sense for me so far. Sweet.
Okay.
Well, if anyone watching is like, I have
no idea what the hell this madman is
talking about. Just comment and I will explain
it. I promise.
Yeah. I've got I've got chat open as
well. So if any comments,
ask questions I can. Sweet. So I
just need this container name.
I'm gonna change that next time I deploy
this
just to be APM so it's easy for
me to use in the command line.
So
we have storage.
Yeah. When logs are stolen by route so
we still need to fix that.
Now they'll be owned by ever the user
of the processes.
So we could change the security context of
that
and do
run as
ID w w data.
Oh, no. Not gonna say that anymore.
82.
Is that ID always going to be the
same or
Yeah. It's built into your image. So But
like, next time you do the build, would
it be 82 stuff?
No. That'll be
set by what the APM, I that that
I would not expect that to change.
Right. You should be safe.
I don't think you can do this. The
reason why is that this security context runs
on the the node essentially is configured as
part of the namespaces that are set up.
So
you will need to use the numeric ID.
Let's try
and I'm gonna rename this actually. Let's do
that now. So
we're gonna just call that's the image Where's
the name? There we go. Let's just call
this fpm so it's easier for me to
get in and we'll call this one
engine x.
Okay. Now we can apply.
Make sure it's running.
And we're gonna exec
IT
and to this
or FTM and ash.
And you can see when I type ID,
I am now WW data.
So I run PS everything as WW data.
This is a much
saner
configuration
and I'm hoping the empty dir
it's done. Okay. So we need to fix
that. And if you don't have the empty
dir at all, would that not just make
it work?
Because Laravel will create a folder if they
need it.
Hey.
So you're Okay. I'll get date account,
yeah.
Yeah. You're you're actually correct. Maybe I'm over
complicating this a little bit.
But also, how come
how come the files are still in by
root? Is that because when we built the
image, it was running as roots?
Yes.
Because
do the do those files not need to
be owned by WW data as well so
that FDM can process them? No. They're readable
by anyone. Something else I would normally do
as well is enable read only file system.
So, you know I actually don't want you
to be able to write to anything which
is why the empty there is important because
that will be somewhere we can write to.
Yeah. I just wish I could remember the
file system thing that I want here.
So we're gonna look it up.
So Kubernetes
security
context
and there is an FS use FS group.
Is that it?
There's FS group.
Yeah. Why is that not all completing for
me? So this might just be the version
of Kubernetes I've got. It doesn't have this
flag anymore.
Let's just put it in and see what
happens.
It's really yelling at me, isn't it?
Unknown field. Okay. Yeah. That must have been
removed then.
So let's see.
Kubernetes
m two dir user
permissions.
There is a way.
If it's group.
Damn it.
Surely, can remove it. They would've got like
a deprecation flag to tell you what anyone's
got.
That seems sensible.
No.
So it's definitely FS group which is good
because I knew that's what it was. I
just don't know how to hand I mean
we could use it in a container. I'd
like to try and avoid that of course.
In fact, am I doing that in the
wrong place? That's what it is.
So this is the security in context for
the pod. I bet you if I
yeah. There we go.
That should create.
So do we want the user to be
on
on the spec, not on the pod or
not?
It depends what user we have inside the
engine x. So let's let's take a look
at that.
Take a look at our password file, which
is our source of users.
Yeah. Engine x runs as one zero one
and we don't have access to w w
w data here.
At least, I mean, don't
see it. Yeah. No. W w w data
is a
Yeah.
Let's try this.
Just curiosity
more than anything there. So
because you're using 82 for the FS group,
but that would be applying it to the
engine x one as well, would it not?
Yep. There's no empty terse there. So Ah,
right. So any applies if there's empty there.
Well,
maybe.
So it will be There we go. So
So you get empty there on the engine
x one as well, you wouldn't be able
specify the f s quick for each individual
container. I'll pop that, would you?
Because they have different IDs.
No. For that, I then be using an
an a container that has a root user
that changes the permission
on the empty there which would be reused
across the end of containers. We
can we can cover that if we think
that it's important
let's just try and let's try and get
this working first and then we can maybe
do some cleanup. So you can see here
we've got our
group right access to here. And in fact,
that empty door just came with explicit permissions
for anybody anyway. So we actually
didn't need to do that, but it's I
think it's that
configuration parameter hopefully is useful for others if
you're looking at a similar situation.
Let's put forward.
Eighty eighty.
So we should be able to write the
logs.
And now it's complaining that we've got some
configuration mission. So this is gonna be that
dot ENV file that you mentioned. Right? Yes.
Is. Yeah. Okay. So now we need a
config map.
So
let's create config
map dot YAML
spec this out. This is our Laravel config
map.
Okay.
So there is a secret value in here.
I'm not that fussed about it being secret
because I'm just gonna delete the key and
play account probably. I'm never gonna use that
mail thingy again. So I'm just not gonna
be too fussed about exposing Yeah.
You could you could just after the after
this
screen share, you can just click the refresh
button and watch out your views. Right. Nice.
Okay.
So
we we really just want this ENV file
to be exposed
as environment variables and a conflict map is
ideal way to do that. Now some of
this isn't actually
some of this I would bake into my
image. I'm not gonna get
dogmatic about that now and we can talk
about that
once I've got it working.
But like, know, the app name isn't something
I'm gonna wanna change
per environment.
ConfigMaps to me should only ever change
variance
for environmental
things. Everything else should be baked into the
image. The app name
yeah. I'd probably put it in the docker
image somewhere.
Yeah. There is something built into Laravel already
as well, which is
you can sort of cache the
what I call, config.
So
which is the dot m v files and
other things that are used for the application.
They can all get cached, and there's a
command to do that. So it doesn't actually
read anything from the environment.
However, that would require it to be then
stored within the actual image itself, but enough.
So
I guess that's a decision that you can
make. I'm sure there's a
yeah. We'll talk about that in a moment.
I'm sure I could, like reject. I'm I'm
kinda looking at it going, I'll just be
quicker to type it.
But it's the better me going, I could
just reject all this.
I am gonna do it. So Yeah.
So what we want to do is
What you want to do is just change
the equals to a column enter. Yep.
Why is that not let me oh, does
my Versus code VEM not support that?
Time for trustee command d on
the guess, you
know you know it's gonna happen
or just command f. Yeah. Let's just do
it this way. So
change equals
to a colon space.
Go.
And then, okay.
So now we need to yeah. That needs
to be a string.
Billions not supported.
Now we want our host. So this is
gonna be the service name that we've provided,
which I believe is MariaDB.
We can run get services.
Yep.
So we have our database available at that
name on that port. That's our database. Our
username is Laravel and our password is Laravel.
This would be a secret.
Let's get it working with Sarah and then
clean it up. Don't let me forget that.
Yeah. I won't. Don't worry.
Broadcast driver, I don't know what that means.
I don't know what that means. Just think
we don't use it. So I think all
those ones, we didn't care about that. The
session driver actually
we don't we're not using sessions in this.
We're fine. We can know that. In production,
I would normally change that to Redis or
database.
Do we need the AWS access stuff? No.
That's just because you can but with
the file system plug ins, you can upload
straight to us by
by
default, so that's all.
How come it's complaining about numbers like 25,
20 five?
I thought YAML supports integers and that.
It does.
What's it saying?
I think the contact map just expects a
string to be honest. Yeah.
Like everything strings is We're not running memcached.
We're not running reddish.
No. I can also go. Alright.
I think
that will be enough. So let's apply that
now
and then update our deployment to use it.
So this is really easy.
What needs to is it NGINX or is
it FPM?
Both?
FPM would be what requires it because it's
PHP for a process that's running. Yes. Okay.
So ENV from ConfigMapRef.
The name of the conflict map. Oh, what
did they call it? Laravel?
Yep.
So does that just, like, basically
export
inside of the image before it was it?
Yes. It will take all of these keys
and make them environment variables, which is how
Laravel works. I don't even need to change
anything.
Yep.
So
let's reapply our deployment.
So that would behave basically the exact same
way as if you'd baked into the image
before you deployed it at all, I guess.
It would just be a Linux
environment variable. Mhmm. Yep. Alright.
Let's see how far we are now.
The application key might not like that. I'm
not sure. Oh, okay.
Let's check our logs.
Yeah.
But that's one of the things I was
gonna complain about next, right, is we'd actually
don't want to log to a file in
any container environment.
That is generally a full path. And you
wanna log the standard out.
So
first let's look at the logs and then
change that.
So
our problem is
it's trying to write to something and we
have a read only fail system.
What's it trying to write to?
Oh, it caches your views.
So framework views is like
it's a cache thing because it comes with
something called blade, which is a template language
like Twig and that sort of stuff on
that sort of stuff thing. So it tries
to write those two
problems. Yes. And I don't think there's always
an opportunity as I have no idea how
to do that. But that's just this framework
folder. Right? Yeah.
Yeah. I assume that all of those have
been trying to do it into sessions, cache.
I don't know what testing is as you
when you want tests
and also views. Okay. So that's all empty.
So what I'm gonna do is empty that
too.
Yep.
Believe that they wanna try and keep this
as a read only file system for as
long as possible before I've met defeat.
So we'll bring in this cache
and we're gonna mount that.
So would you normally have like a
a temp to sort of things that could
be written to for
say, if somebody was to upload a file
that needed processing before getting moved on to
that s three, would you have, like, a
temp to
configure which is Rawkode and then we got?
Yes. So I would definitely use the volumes
key up here to provide something that was
ephemeral. Now I would use an empty dir
definitely for like a local Kubernetes environment and
some production environments. I may like if I
need to guarantee that file exists after a
pod restart, I'd probably use like a persistent
volume or a host path depending on how
my cluster is configured but I would use
a volume of some kind for anything that
needs right access.
The reason being this like, you know most
attacks especially against PHP
based content management systems is generally through some
really contrived and illegal upload that executes an
arbitrary script and then rewrites over your code
And you could just say you know, that's
one read only file system argument
to stop solve that. As long as you
don't mind going through the process
of making sure you could write to your
logs and your cache which I'm gonna try
and do now.
Let's try.
We deploy.
Let's get our pods. Oh, and let's change
the login to standard out. Like, we don't
wanna log to a file anyway. We wanna
be able to use the logs command.
So
how do I configure that with Laravel?
Change the ENV to STDERR.
Just send it out.
So what am I changing? Change stack there
to STDERR.
Is that correct? One one d.
Awesome. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That was it.
There's also I'm sure that's your rate to
standard out. Right? Yeah. That just send it
straight to standard out. Okay. Let's do that.
Let's reapply
and make sure I'm in the position that
I kinda wanna be in. So
I'll yeah. That's the config map I need
to deploy.
And then I'll easily delete the pod to
get that new configuration.
So now I should
be able to run logs against this.
And I have the FPM logs.
Now if you hit the
browser,
you should see something logged, I think, because
I don't think we fixed the error that
we have before, did we? I
hope so.
Let me run the port forward from another
location.
We
can keep our logs up.
I was gonna split my terminal, but I
think that's just gonna make it more confusing.
Alright. So there is our logs.
But something's logging. So that's
looks like that's in the next setup.
No. No. That's FBM. And we got a
500. Okay. So the Laravel log configuration is
obviously obviously not
quite as simple as that.
I'm assuming that we're still gonna have something
in that storage
logs.
Yeah.
Yep.
Let's just cat it. So
what failed
on car and valley?
Hang on. Sorry. You just put unable to
create Unable to create logger. Standard out is
not defined.
Just oh, so I trusted you. So
It's option. I'm looking at the code now.
It is there.
If you open up the code in configs
last I'd expect it to be dev standard
out.
Like that.
That's good. That's what it's here for. Right?
So log to standard out.
And there's another option which we can just
use our log, which will put it in
the FPM log by default, and that should
put it into the standard log for standard
error log.
Alright.
What we have already should work, so I
don't understand it.
That won't work
because that
where it's being passed through to monologue, the
PHP
logging library.
I see.
Okay.
FPM.
The
pod. Yeah.
We're gonna have to add a service so
I don't have to keep doing that, but
let's do it one more time for now.
Alright.
Let's go back in.
FPM
storage
logs
cat
log.
Did that fail to set up? Please provide
a valid cache path.
Unable to create configured logger.
Is this because of the empty dev that
you created framework? I think it expects for
the cash flow to exist. You might create
multiple entities.
I don't think it might not create that
file folder.
Okay. I'm also worried about this logger.
Yeah. No. That that's definitely an issue.
So I need to create a good logger,
but to me
I'll
leave that as an exercise for another day
set up logging rather
than And if you change up to syslog,
you just try that one last one last
thing for syslog because that should put it
straight through as well, would it not? No.
Syslog may look for syslog in the container
which one exists.
Oh, okay.
Alright. Let's ignore it.
And let's do
cash and we're gonna need sessions.
And again, I don't really wanna spend too
much time fighting on things that aren't that
important. So I can always just disable that
if this doesn't work. Is there anything else
required in the framework directory?
Views.
I think there's one called testing as well.
We measure main model. I don't know what
testing is.
Right. Do I have them here?
Storage,
framework, cache sessions, testing, Right. Okay.
I mean, I I would just expect it
to create them if they're not there. I
find that. I I I do as well,
but that's all I can
choose.
Okay.
Modifier deployment.
Oh, yeah. I've got to actually add them.
So we need testing
sessions.
Yes.
Alright.
Take 16.
But we're not gonna get any logs. Okay.
So
let's just fix the port forward.
Right. That's progress. We're not gonna white screen
anymore.
So
let's see where we are.
FPM
ash storage logs cat
log.
So now it's complaining.
Oh, yes. So it doesn't like my I
just put in a random string there. What's
that supposed to be?
There's some r sank commands. HP r s
n key colon generate.
If you just run that inside of the
APM container,
that should
key colon generate.
It's trying to write it to ENV. Don't
I'll create one locally and just send it
here.
Can I not just print it out?
Yeah. Right. Sure. Well, there we go. Okay.
Okay. Cool. Nice.
I hate it when tools are fighting against
me rather than
doing my bidding. Right. Okay.
I've noticed it with three sixty four before
that's interesting.
Or maybe that's just a help. No. No.
It's all up. That's fine.
Alright.
Let's just apply that whole directory for a
bit of quickness.
Make sure our pods rotate.
Oh, I only change the config map. So
I need to delete my pods myself.
And now we can put forward again.
And finally,
I'm really hoping we see a database migration
that are here.
Oh, our application worked. It
really might get nice because we're not acquiring
any databases
at the moment. But that is proving that
the asset completion works as well because
that's using tailwind to get the data there.
Alright. It's production now. I'll see you later.
Thanks.
So that's actually covered one of the things
on the list anyway, though. That's the secrets
and environment stuff. There is something on my
list, has happened a few times whilst you've
been doing that, which
I assume is not the right way of
doing it. You've just been deleting pods
to get it to basically redeploy.
Uh-huh.
Probably
a better way of doing it than that,
I assume.
Unfortunately,
not. So the the problem is is that
when you modify a config map, it gets
updated in real time pretty much within your
deployment.
So like the files will just be synced
up to there as a fail man. I
think the environment variables.
I think they still update in real time,
I can confirm but I'm not a %
confident. Your application is really expected to notice
those changes and reload
but most applications don't.
One of the ways to get around it
is to include the shove, the conflict map
as an annotation on your deployment which forces
a reload every time you modify the conflict
map. It's a bit hacky
and there are some controllers that can also
run inside the cluster that monitor for changes
in the conflict map and rotate your pods
for you.
So there's a few ways to do it
but honestly for the this kind of environment,
the lean is the right way to do
it. However, somebody who said that we tackled
that we haven't was secrets.
I wouldn't put a secret in this file.
Sure. Yeah. So let's fix that. Let's take
out this app key
and let's create a secret channel.
I know and this is really good if
it's gonna feel weird because
I'm solving one problem
at a very similar way to the conflict
map anyway and I'll try do my best
to explain why this is more, why this
is better.
So,
So
this is a secret.
I am storing this as Yamo and my
repository right now. So it's no more secret
than a config map.
Granted.
However, you're very unlikely to apply your secrets
to your cluster in this way. You may
be using vault or some other KMS system
to provide these as to get these into
your cluster but you want them to be
a secret inside of your cluster because they
have different RBAC rules compared to a conflict
map, Right? It's generally conflict maps have loose
our back. Most people can have access to
them. They're also consumable from within the pods.
You wanna be able to lock that down
and you wanna be able to lock the
pods down as well so that nobody can
exec into it and just grab the secret.
So
while
from a very
naive perspective and look at it, naive is
the wrong word, from a very well from
this example it doesn't seem like we're improving
the security at all just by using the
secrets you are as long as you get
them into the environment correctly.
The other thing I wanna kinda cover is
that
well, for a start this will fail. There's
two keys on a secret.
String data and
data
actually
expects
your data to be base 64 encoded.
So if I do base 64,
paste this in
and grab this.
In fact, that's not gonna work because of
the new lane. So let me just copy
that properly.
We should actually done like echo
dash n,
which means no new line. Right? Yeah.
And then base 64
and this will get us add to value.
So both of these are correct. So
when I apply and the fact, let's just
change
this. So we'll call this string key instead
of that key. I can't remember if the
Kubernetes control plane will allow me to have
data and string data but we're gonna push
our luck and see what happens.
So
yeah, it doesn't care. Cool.
Now we should actually see that both these
values are the same.
So we'll grab our Laravel dash o Yamo.
If I could spell secret.
If we look at the data fields,
yeah. You see we actually get the same
value here.
So string data is a helper that when
you apply something to the cluster at knows
that you haven't base 64 encoded it yet
and it will base 64 encoded for you
regardless you get the same value at other
end. String data, a helper good in some
environments
data base 64 encoded, not a secret
but again you wouldn't apply secrets typically in
this fashion.
For production use cases you would use like
SOPs, Fry Mozilla,
sealed secrets
or my personal favorite, the Kapitan project.
So these all handle it slightly differently.
Stops and sealed secrets will use well in
fact they all they all do it the
same way, they all encrypt stuff but the
way that you interact with the tool is
slightly different.
I don't know if it's gonna be like
a quick thingy here.
No, because you don't have a Kubernetes specific
thing. It doesn't matter.
So stops allows you to encrypt it and
store the encrypted file within get which means
you can apply it. You just have to
remember your continuous integration pipeline to be to
decrypt it before you do the the apply
and there are some things that can run-in
a cluster to try and make that easier
and more secure, but it's a really good
way of doing it. Sealed secrets does the
same. It stores a private key inside of
your Kubernetes cluster. You can use the sealed
secrets command line to reach out, encrypt the
value and you get a text based secret
like this with obviously an encrypted string which
is still secret
and then finally there's the Kapitan project which
does secret management and hooks up to all
the key messes and vault. So if you're
already deploying to cloud provider web at key
mess, this is honestly, this is just the
best way to do it and you can
define them and you have all and they'll
be they'll be encrypted for you and only
decryptable and a cluster that access to that
KMS, so you can use cloud provider I'm
rules.
I'm not gonna say any more about it
because secrets would be deviate and has done
a path of a lot of time and
I don't wanna take up too much of
your time and in fact we only have
like twenty five minutes left. So
let's see.
Did that all make sense? That wasn't too
much waffle.
That makes sense to me.
I need to do something kind of similar
in Ansible where you use Ansible Bolt, but
that would have you'd have the encrypted locally,
so in here, and then when you're trying
to play it and try and deploy it,
you use you provide your vault key, which
is just the password you type in at
deployment time and encrypt
it and send the values over.
We do something kinda similar to what sounds
like
a soft one.
And no surprises.
We pass our secret through in exactly the
same way. There are finer grade controls, can
mount on specific keys and make them optional,
change the names within the container,
there's a bunch of stuff you can do.
Okay.
Let's make sure we haven't broken anything.
Let's apply that whole directory.
Here's our new pod
port forward.
We should still see.
Right. Okay.
Can't believe we started off saying, let's run
database migrations. We're like
fair chunk of our way through this. We
haven't done it yet. So let's actually run
these migrations now. So Kubernetes expects us to
leverage something called an edit container.
Now if we go to our container definition
here,
we
can just say edit containers
and we can provide it a name, we'll
call this database
migrations
and it takes pretty much is that same
spec that you're using
for the fact that is the same spec
for your containers,
you're just trying to override the behavior in
a way that makes sense for you to
run certain commands. So you know here I'm
gonna say run
FPM.
The thing I wanna change is that I
need access to well, I wanna run a
different command.
I wanna run PHP
and then I'm gonna provide some arcs.
The arcs are gonna be
artisan
DB.
Is that right?
Just just migrate. Maybe Just migrate. So just
PHP artisan migrate.
Yep. And then you'll also need to do
double dash false, I think, because it will
by default for a warning saying you're running
this in a production environment.
Alright.
Let's just do it.
I'm feeling an entry point because it that
needs to enter at the
Kubernetes doesn't call it an entry point. So
in Kubernetes, they use same language. So it's
command and args,
whereas Docker, yes, they would call an entry
point. So what mean is
for the file path of where you're running
PHP or send from.
No. Because every time I've exec into that
container, you have put me into the work
in there which seems to be the correct
location.
Okay. If I manage to set up properly,
that is pure coincidence. Yeah.
And your Docker file. Now let me just
because you haven't done it for NGINX but
you have done it for for
FPM.
So That's here. Work there. Okay. Yeah. You
you would want that in your NGINX one
as well. Now I forgot to set the
image pool policy to never, which is why
that's failing.
So let's top that up.
So you don't have expect to never in
because you're doing this locally. If I was
doing this on a production, you get rid
all of the neighbors and the actual path
of the image would be
private.docker.com/whatever.
Yeah. You would include the container registry. I
like to run my own registry within my
clusters that caches the images. I generally use
a pool policy
of, you know, if it's not available, if
it's not present on the on the machine.
I don't do an always pool generally because
I do use
I I don't use ephemeral tags like latest
and such that, you know, I would use
a proper content
You just need something. Yeah. So
alright. Let's see why this is failing. I'm
assuming that the migrate command is trying to
write to a fail probably
and that my we're gonna have to sacrifice
my read only fail system, but let's see.
I don't believe that it does write any
files.
We want the logs for the database migrations.
We're getting connection refused.
Okay.
So
Did do you create
I didn't give it the environment variables.
Ah, okay. Yeah. That is
So we need this to be copied
to here.
Let's reapply
and see
what we got.
It worked.
You don't seem convinced.
I typically check the database to make sure
my breaking work, but, you know Alright. So
let's grab this. Let's do see database
migrations.
Yep. There we go. Oh, okay. Yeah. That
worked.
Is there an endpoint in your Laravel application
that will allow us to consume that database
at all?
Yep. So I've created a few endpoints. One
of them is called create dash posts,
and that will create just five
five posts in the areas.
Create
slash post or dash post?
Like so?
Yep. I know that's a little difficult to
read, but
So that should've done it. I didn't give
any up, by the way. It thought it'd
in white. That's fine. Can I is there
a get posts?
That is a get post. Oh, no. No.
Sorry. No. If you go to slash posts.
There you go. That works. Js. But yeah.
Here you go.
Great. Awesome. So is working. That's Yeah. Really
simple. I mean, and it containers they are
the best way to handle this thing. Of
course there are caveats. I'm not gonna say
go and add this to all applications immediately.
They need to be at important. You have
to be able to run them. These will
like in fact, let's show that when I
scale this up to five, those migrations are
gonna run on every deployment every time I
kill a pod. So you really need to
make sure that they
don't collide. There's
locking, you know, you're gonna potentially have to
running close to each other and they have
to be item potent.
So I'm assuming with the ORM that Laravel
is using that you get all that free.
Most ORMs do provide something like that so
you should be good.
I'm not sure about other issues though because
they are quite good on,
like,
the whole, like, high availability side of things.
So I'd assume that that's something to do.
I would assume your your migrate commander does
a lock on the entire database.
And in fact, we could probably trigger that
by, you know, deleting the database, spending it
back up empty, running a migrate, and trying
to create posts at the same time or
get posts at the same time. We'd probably
see it wait for a while before it
got access to the table again or the
database.
Okay. What what's next on your list? What
we've got? Twenty minutes. So queue jobs is
probably the big one. Queue and scheduled jobs.
Alright. So Kubernetes exposes a primitive
called jobs,
which are just like cron jobs.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to
oh, I do. I love this plugin.
So
we have, you know, just like all our
other Kubernetes manifests,
really simple specification
and we can specify this is the time
to second time to live seconds after finished.
Who knows what that is to have help?
Later on the job is finished execution.
Yeah. Whatever. Okay. We specify the container and
we specify the command. Now,
you'll also wanna be able to tweak when
this runs.
I'm using the wrong object.
Crack up.
Is that Cronghold? I'm gonna show my own
ignorance. I've never been able to remember how
this works there. Kubernetes.
I spent a lot of my time in
documentation.
There we go. There is a thing called
cron jobs. Yeah. I just couldn't remember what
this was.
So it's not too much because I've seen
like online but Alright. That's batch v one.
Some
things just prefer to v one and some
things refer to like something document.vone.
Yeah. I'm
not sure why that yelled at me then.
Maybe it's because the spec was wrong
or maybe it never maybe that's not been
promoted yet actually. So
yeah. Okay.
It's not cron jobs haven't had a view
on yet but jobs have so
There you go.
Let's just copy the whole thing and modify
it to to do our bidding. So we'll
call this Laravel. I'm just gonna keep calling
everything Laravel. We can use regular cron sales
syntax to specify the job.
I
don't know how to generate that most of
the time.
I just do $5.
Yeah. Cron maker. I think this is the
one I use.
Just say run every five minutes.
Why wouldn't you just do star star star
star star?
I have we because you want it to
run every minute?
The current helper and the Laravel
then
inside inside of the
the console kernel determines what jobs inside of
that should run and at what frequency. So
you would run this every minute.
Okay. So I guess I don't understand. I
I've never built a Laravel application, so let's
try and cover a few basic questions then.
Now as the queue processor,
a long running process that should be deployed
as a deployment or as a cron job
that runs regularly? Oh, sorry. Sorry. It depends
are we dealing with acute job here or
are we dealing with the scheduled tasks? Because
there there's two things that need to be
in anyway.
Okay. So I'm assuming the scheduled tasks is
a cron job. Right? Yes. Okay.
And you would just star star star star
star star It's just straight up every minute
when it
and then all you do is you have
like, the migrate command, you have one entry
point which is just a schedule call on
run, I think.
Yeah. Schedule call on run.
Once you've run that every minute, it just
deals with itself based on your PHP code.
Okay. So we'll call this
scheduled.
This is the same FPM image. What command
are we running?
Schedule colon run.
Is that all?
Believe so. Let me just check if there's
a force that's needed.
Yeah. No. That's it.
Alright. Let's apply it. So
jobs
and then like all the other Kubernetes resources,
we type get jobs.
Oh, no. A cron job. I call that
a job. Yeah. Here we go.
Okay. And we can wait.
Let's within a minute, should see a pod
to get scheduled, which will spin up, run
that command, shut that down and then that'll
loop every minute doing the same thing. And
by pure coincidence,
we're about to hit quarter past and I've
got a job in there that every five
minutes sends an email.
So we should see that it sends an
email. Just
pure coincidence on that, but we should see
that actually executes that job and just what
we are gonna do. So we should see
that email.
What was that? Was it mail Mail trap.
The I o. Yeah.
So
Oh, it crashed. Oh, no.
Is it trying to write to a file?
It will be, won't it? I don't think
it should write to a file.
Alright. Let's see. Unless it ends up maybe
it writes like a cache file thing. Oh,
no. Could not open input fail schedule run.
What have I got wrong? Oh, you did
get the artisan. Artisan.
Hello.
What? I didn't know from that.
Software crashed.
Okay. No. We
actually had a few comments there as well.
We were too busy focused on that. So
Frank and Nate both commented that we missed
the hours and thank you.
So that's
the fact I kind of I don't know
if I applied that because
I got really confused when you disappeared and
then realized the software crashed.
Yeah. That's right.
These things like reconnect and stuff.
Yeah. So it says unchanged.
Here we go. So we we this is
now completing every minute. We've had two of
them since the crash. Obviously, this one failed.
So do we know what not to kill
itself off immediately as soon as it's got
the exit?
There's no need for a time to life
on that. Is that because it's never going
to reuse the same command again?
We'll leave it for now. I don't think
it's
terribly important.
Well, they clean themselves up once the CTL
gets hit, I guess then.
Yeah. Did that just crash again?
Oh, that's that's just a broken one. So
I can just delete that.
Because would that not mean that every minute
a new pod is created and that isn't
being cleared out.
Eventually, we're just gonna have memory from that.
No. These ones are gone. They're completed. So
they they don't take up any resources anymore.
So Oh, okay. Okay.
So that seems okay.
I guess if we wait another two minutes,
we should see the email come in here
Yeah. At at twenty past. But you said
there was one other type of job, so
let's try and handle that one then.
Yeah. So this is the more,
I guess, complicated one.
What you can have in Laravel is
queue jobs. So you can queue it up
using various different queue drivers,
SES, and you can play database, Redis,
all those sort of things.
But the way of using that is the
same server doesn't make any difference to us.
What we want to do there is have
a command that's running long term. It's a
long running process in the background that
runs the r s n q colon work.
That's all that we require.
But then it gets a bit more complicated
than that. You can have different named queues
and have different number of workers per queues
and and things like that, I guess.
Yeah. That's just gonna be a new deployment
for me. I mean, long run-in process means
it's a deployment. I wanna be able to
scale up and down depending on how many
workers I want as well as tweaking the
parameters.
So, know, we could I mean, we probably
would just copy this
and call it
queue worker.
We're not gonna need the NGINX so we
can remove that. Mhmm.
Do we do you think we'll need logs,
cache test? I'm gonna in fact, you know,
I'm just gonna keep it. I don't wanna
I think we'd need it all because the
framework will still hit those. Well, maybe not
like views and stuff, but if they're bad,
it's gonna be easy to do. Alright.
So we update our labels to be queue
worker
queue worker
and then we just modify the command. We
don't need
container at all.
And here we're just gonna see,
we don't specify the command we're using the
and built one. So here we just say
PHP again.
We specify the args.
We're gonna run sorry. What was the command?
Artisan.
Artisan
and then q colon work.
Q work.
Colon.
Yeah. And then you need to pass so
that will work by default. That will run
the what's called
all the three queues in Laravel are named,
and the default one is just called default.
But what you can do is you can
then pass through double dash q equals
and give it a concept based string of
different queues. So you could put just default
that and that from the default one.
So you you have different high high and
low priority queues. You can make the high
priority queue have 10 workers, low priority have
two workers, and that's something for the purpose.
Yeah. And and that's that exact reason is
why I would use its own deployment
for each of the different queue semantics I've
got so that I can really define the
quality of service and how quickly I need
to process and how many workers and how
many replicas. Like not all queues, I would
imagine at least in applications I've written in
the past would be considered equal and I'd
wanna be able to tweak that. It may
seem like, I'll just add a new pod,
add a new container to my main pod
but I don't think that would be necessarily
the right way to handle that.
Let's apply.
Where are we?
Queue workers. Right. We now have five queue
workers. Can we do we can we confirm
that?
Yes. We can. So in the rooms, if
you go to slash queue dash jobs, it
will should send three emails.
Oh, first of all, if we check the
email provider, we should have an email from
the con job in there now.
Tada.
Nice. So
that means the cron's working. That's great. And
so all new alignment. That's all working fine.
Now if you hit q
dash
jobs,
it should send three more emails off.
There we go.
There we have our queue workers.
Easy peasy.
So there's something that you can because Pigfy
isn't really designed for long running, at least
it was never initially designed for long running
jobs.
It's kind of basically a a sort of
hacky way of doing it. The key worker
is that moment. And so you can sometimes
get many issues with that. So Laravel does
provide something called max jobs, which is another
flag in your past, which means that it'll
kill off that that worker
and send, like, an exit signal to it
after x number of jobs. If you were
to do that with the
container,
would that spin up a new one, which
is what you'd expect? Or would that then
start, like, a whole cascade of issues?
Yeah. What what I would use is the
resource limits here. You know, I I've already
defined how much how many resources I'm happy
for these queue workers to consume. So like
Kubernetes is gonna restart it when it when
it starts to break these limits anyway.
Okay. You wouldn't really need to hook into
the Laravel aspect there. I would just rely
on the container scheduling to go, hey, I
don't really want you to consume in 14
gig of RAM, I'm gonna restart you now.
That's cool. So That's that's his job. Don't
have yourself. That's fine. And what's the 500
m? That wasn't really covered earlier, I guess,
for the CPU. So a single CPU is
broken down into 1,000 units.
I think they're called milli cores. So you
can say this is essentially me saying the
half a core. This this process is restricted
to half a core of the host machine.
Does that does that translate to roughly, like,
every one and two instructions?
Like, so if there's two pods on there,
both given half a core,
they will, like, sort of alternate who can
get access or is or is that just
like No. So it depends on how many
cores are available on the machine. So like,
I'm not sure if I'm gonna be able
to get that information from Kubernetes
here. In fact,
let's see how permissive our thing is.
So containers
don't necessarily obscure the view of the proc
fail system.
So typically
you can just pop in here
and you'll still see the actual host information.
So you could see here I've got processors
which means if I set this to
4,000
m and
scale this,
we've got it set on five. Yeah. We
won't see all five of those schedule.
We should see that fail. So
yeah. There we go.
We we have pending queue workers and if
I
describe
one of those, it'll tell me that the
resources aren't available
and sufficient CPU.
Okay. Right.
Not
it's not like
how it allocates it. So
Well, it's because we're using a limit. Right?
I mean, I could have said
requests
which means I kinda want this but it's
not a hard request, know, if it's available,
give me it. Whereas a limit is like,
it's actually gonna set aside half a quart
for that process
and it's gonna set aside 50 mega ram
for that process and it won't allow me
to schedule. So there's still contention for any
pods that are running on the machine, they're
still competing for resources dependent on the instructions
we're sending but the scheduler is gonna go,
I know at some point this is gonna
have
4,000 milli cores of CPU and I'm not
gonna schedule anything that tries to go beyond
that. Whereas if I leave this as request,
we should see that
adjust
I think it will actually schedule most of
the time.
Because they're not using that many at that
time.
Oh, no. I okay. So the scheduler is
gonna say no as well. Alright. So
but yeah. The request is kinda given the
scheduler a hand of what you need. The
limits means restart the process of every goes
beyond it and then the schedule will do
its best to make sure you schedule on
a note where it's not gonna have too
much contention for those
So Okay. Yeah. That makes sense.
Okay. That is
actually to be fair, everything apart from
one thing on my list for the pretty
much. So What did we not cover?
Release cycle. So how would you not go
about doing the natural like full on release?
Not necessarily with like CI's of thought. You
build a new image, it needs to be
deployed.
Can you go in with QCTL,
delete the pods?
How would you automate that or something? No.
I mean it'll it'll handle that for you
so let's assume
and we can do this in two minutes.
So
yeah, let's use our queue worker. Right?
So firstly, let's just remove these limits
so we can get all five and let's
change the image. Let's say instead of, you
know, normally we would change the tag here
to be v 54
or whatever. Right? But what if I just
wanna say deploy engine x?
So the way that this works is if
I just deploy this and run this really
quickly,
is it
oh, container errors.
Let's just take off all this stuff that
we don't need. The security context is why
that's failing
and the command won't exist. But there's a
whole lot of why that was failing. So
so again for trying to do it too
quickly. Right. Okay. That's
pretty generic.
So let's reapply that and then run this.
What we're gonna see is that
and it's it's fast so it's difficult. Right?
But we actually spun up two
new ones before shutting down the first one
then we spun up a third and then
we started scheduling two more after that and
then it starts terminating.
So on top of a deployment object, actually
have the ability to specify the
the strategy
and then we can have a type
and a rolling update, rolling
update
which allows us to specify a search
or a max unavailable.
So
the deployment already knows how to do safe
deploys with new images. You have to tell
it to do the rolling update which is
actually happens by default and you get a
max surge of
one I think. You can also use percentages
so you could say that I want 25%
of my pods to be unavailable. That means
that it will sacrifice, let's assume, sorry, lots
of information.
Let's assume I have 10 pods running, if
I have a max unavailable of 25%,
it's gonna be able to shut down 25%
of those pods which is two. If it
was 50% it would shut down five and
then it would spin up new ones. If
we go with a surge approach what we
say is I have 10
with a max surge of 50, I'll actually
schedule up to 15
and then once five are healthy shut down
five and then spin up more.
Okay. So so with that in
combination or we use one or the other?
You can only use one or the other.
So you can let's
let's double check. Right? Because I've been wrong
a few times a day anyway but
I didn't care. Okay. I guess you can
use them both together. I thought you could
only pick one. So, here I could say
I I always need at least 75%
to be running and I don't mind scheduling
over provisioning by 50%. And then the scheduler
will work all out for you. You don't
need to worry about it too much. Okay.
Okay. So in terms of
when when you do release, you'd normally have
a
your deployment process, your CIO, whatever, would tag
a new version of the image and then
would you
do, like, a cube apart a cube CTL
apply and that would then start pulling in
the new images for you? It's it's definitely
how I would start my, you know, my
continuous integration deployments ever would just reply over
the top with that new tag or whatever
I'm using and that Kubernetes had up from
there and then eventually you can start to
look at things like, you know, get ops,
continuous deployment from within the cluster and get
a little bit more sophisticated doing progressive rollouts
making sure that, you know, the metrics don't
change for the first ten minutes at 10%
traffic and then scaling up. We could do
a couple of more episodes on that. I'm
not gonna be able to do it justice
and like ten seconds but Yeah. You could
definitely start with a cube control apply and
then take it from there.
Okay. That sounds good. Alright. That's cool. Everything
I think so. Yeah. We we covered it
a lot.
What I'll suggest is I hope people find
this useful. Leave comments or anything that you
want us to tackle on a future episode.
I'm sure Alex would be happy to join
me. Alex and I'll have our own conversations
and work out what else we can do
in the future. We definitely wanna I've already
got an idea of what we should probably
hate before, so we'll cover that out of
outside of the screen.
Alright. Well, thank you for joining me, Alex.
It was an absolute pleasure. I had fun
doing that. I'll see you for the next
one. Goodbye, everyone. Cheers.